firms would be required to take steps to
help customers repay their balances more
quickly and to offer further assistance
to those who can't 3.3 million people
are thought to be in persistent dest
costing customers an average to pound 50
for every pound repaid among the moves
being considered are the suspending of
credit cards are struggling customers
while they pay off their debt credit
card companies could also reduce waive
or cancel interest or charges where a
payment plan is still unaffordable and
customers who fail to cooperate or who
can't afford a repayment plan should
lose their credit cards so the rules
we're proposing are that firms have to
play a role now in helping people who
are in persistent debt what that means
is 18 months after someone's been in
persistent there for 18 months there
contacted by the firm they're told about
some of their options as we go forward
if that continues for a further 18
months then the firm has to put in a
plan to make sure that those debts are
affordable and repayable Peter Totten is
the head of policy at debt charity
step-change Peter is it too easy to get
credit in this country we've seen credit
markets are growing very strongly at the
moment credit standards have been
falling we've seen in the past how that
can get people into difficulty our
warriors will see that again
credit cards are the biggest most common
debt that we see about two-thirds of our
clients have one or more credit card
debts with an average balance of about
eight thousand so it's quite easy
particularly things like credit cards we
can get quite a big credit limit and
quite very low minimum repayments for
people to fall into difficulty over time
oh there's some issuers who are worse
than others I mean for example rollback
has gotten three years ago did away with
teaser rates which was applauded at the
time has been quite a good thing other
some people worse than others well I
think we see sort of issues right across
the market so for us the issue is about
how we deal with problem debt
how we stop people falling into
persistent credit card debt and what's
the best way to people help people out
of that now lenders are capable of doing
good things we see good practice from
all lenders but also we see bad practice
and more lenders so there's something
here about consistency one of the things
in the FCA proposals they say firms need
to do more to help one of the things we
would like the FCA to have said more
about is how
should help people at the moment is left
up to firms they can do good things they
don't always do good things so you
broadly happy with what's been announced
today well we think it's a start there's
some good things in there actually we
think the FCA should have gone further
this is about dealing with people who
are in persistent credit card debt even
after those remedies are in place it
seems that some people could still be
paying their debts off credit card it's
off of 10 years or or in some cases you
know seven years at credit card rates of
interest so let's remember these are
products that are designed for
short-term borrowing and priced
accordingly they're quite expensive to
use them for long term borrowing they
get really expensive so we think the FCA
could have actually gone further and got
firms to take action a bit quicker to
help people to more affordable more
manageable borrowing you say they could
have gone further I mean your own
charities chairman is Sir Hector Sanz
used to run the FSA which was the FCA's
predecessor he didn't do too much about
this today well the FCA has started for
a for a while they're on a journey they
took over credit in 2014 so the old FSA
didn't regulate credit in the way the
FCA has done they've done some good
things they've done some things on
payday lending and now they're turning
attention to credit cards they're going
to have to turn their attention to
overdrafts and other issues they're not
quite there yet we hope they will get
there it's a question of drilling down
into these problems slowly but steadily
as I say what they've announced today is
something that makes a difference and
the idea that firms can't just sit there
and leave their customers in persistent
debt where they racking the profits
they've got to intervene and help people
so but more to do to make that effective
where does personal responsibility come
into all this so Peter I mean surely all
these people that bite off more than
they they can chew I mean surely they
should be shouldn't they just be tipped
into bankruptcy and then live with the
consequences in terms of having credit
ration to them in future well what we
see most of the people or nearly all of
the people we see will be able to take
on a Ford credit when they take it on
the problem is that when you take on
more credit your vulnerability to a
change in circumstances increases so
there's something that a length is a
much better understanding people's
vulnerability to debt than consumers are
people often say to us what I thought I
could afford it because the bank told me
I could and it's that change in
circumstances that often tips people
over now bankruptcy is a good solution
for some people what
when people who financial difficulty
they need help with their debts for many
people the first port of call has to be
help from their lender and we hope that
we'll get better for this